first of all just because somebody is of
a particular group does not mean they're
right or indeed potato
it doesn't always by any means if if
ever mean they have a particular right
to be heard it's true that you wouldn't
want a conversation between a hundred
people about women and none of them to
be women should be
although the Catholic Church has tried
that no math but more than one hundred
but but generally speaking we recognize
that that people do bring confusion
surrounding tirely sure what and what
the what the particular mix is is needed
but nevertheless there isn't a
particular virtue you bring by being of
a characteristic there's a very
brilliant young American writer who
happens to be black called Coleman
Hughes who who mentioned this in an
essay a while ago and I quote him in the
introduction that he said that when he
was a university quite very recent I
think maybe still is in America some of
his contemporaries treated him as if he
had a special moral insight from being
black well think some black people
obviously will have special moral
insights just like people of all sorts
of backgrounds and skin colors will but
but just being black in itself doesn't
doesn't bring that in the same way that
we all know I mean just because you're a
man or just because you're a woman does
not mean you have a magical virtue or
insight there will be things you notice
and there'll be things you can see and
but but that sort of it's that all
depends on the individual it's like if
you said I just think that women are so
clever or something you say well I mean
what do you mean if I say I think men
are all clever are we talking about it's
just there's individuals you point you
depending brilliant women I can appoint
you to plenty brilliant men am but
plenty brilliant black people as well as
plenty brilliant white people but why
would you be doing these categories and
what do you think they bring and I think
in each of them it's very strange is
almost like we sin in the course of my
lifetime I Chavan he just turned 40 but
in the course of my lifetime we've it's
always as if on these things we've gone
past equal and
overcorrected slightly as if because men
and particularly white men have had you
know certain advantages I think there's
a lot to dispute in that interpretation
but that for a bit will be mean to them
I will make white people feel a bit of
the racism that some of them have
expressed in the past to other people in
order to make up for the past this car
is a dream eken ISM to compensate and if
it's the same thing with it's not enough
that women are equal we should also
punish men a bit and on each of these I
think well they're a set of questions
aren't there well how would you know
when you've over corrected who would
announce it what would the signs be and
how would you get back to equal and are
you sure you could you absolutely sure
you would know how to orient yourself it
I mean they're being by that point among
others careers and jobs and pensions of
people who are very happy with the
overcorrection
[Music]
you